this video is brought to you by keeps
[Music]
what's up everybody my name is michael
burns and today for the first time ever
i'm gonna open up about my greatest fear
disney
i'm absolutely terrified of disney
adults let me explain a couple years
back we casually discussed the
phenomenon of adults who are super
enthusiastic about disney on our podcast
culture bench and i shared some
tongue-in-cheek thoughts about the
unaccompanied olds at disney world i get
a little judgy when i see like legit
adults get hella emotional about going
to a kid's park if i was a parent let's
say and i'm taking my kids to disney and
we had to wait to get on a ride because
a bunch of 37 year olds are all like
getting emotional to get on the teacups
or whatever i'm just a little pissed
maybe get out of the way right now or go
to like i don't know the zone where they
have like alcoholic beverages and
churros and just chill there all the
kids go on the rides now i moved on with
my life but a few days later a disney
youtuber posted an entire reaction video
that took
umbrage with my comments i started to
watch it and it kind it deeply disturbed
me and ever since i get regular dms from
dummy accounts threatening my life or
making fun of me or implying that i hate
anyone who didn't have a great childhood
and while sometimes annoying
this experience has mostly left me
wondering
why and this fiery reaction to very tame
criticism has led the team at wisecrack
to investigating an important question
are disney adults
kind of a cult or put more nicely are
they inadvertently practicing their own
religion and if so can their zealotry
tell us anything interesting about
modern society at large let's find out
in this wisecrack edition on disney
adults is disney a religion part one oh
and if you decide to make a reaction
video to this one just tag us in it and
before we get into it just a quick note
while researching this topic we found
way more interesting stuff than could
possibly fit into just one video so
we're splitting this one into a
two-parter sort of like a godfather
godfather part two situation except i'm
not gonna kill my own brother in part
two i know it was you fredo this video
is going to cover some recent disney
adult drama and then contextualize what
we actually mean when we ask if disney
is a religion then in part two we'll
look at the intricacies of how disney
maybe functions as a religion and don't
worry unlike francis ford coppola we
know when to end something great after
two
parts but before we get into it i want
to tell you about this video sponsor
keith keeps is a prescription service
that helps guys prevent hair loss it's
convenient affordable and relevant to a
lot of people out there because two out
of three men experience some form of
male pattern baldness by the time
they're 35 the process begins with a
free consultation with a licensed keeps
doctor who will recommend the fda
approved prescriptions and
over-the-counter medications that best
fit your needs these hair loss
prevention medications will
automatically land at your door every
three months so you don't have to bother
with ordering refills as your treatment
plan goes on you can message your keeps
doctor 24 7 to update them on your
progress and to ask any questions you
may have now it typically takes between
four and six months to start seeing
results so get started today to hang on
to the hair you have if you're ready to
take action and prevent hair loss go to
keeps.com wisecrack or click the link in
the description to receive fifty percent
off your first order that's k e e p s
dot com slash wisecrack now back to the
show now for a little bit of story time
starring ye old internet last month
reddit's am i the [ __ ] forum
spotlighted a recently married couple
who invited their nearest and dearest to
a lavish disney world wedding where they
allegedly instructed their guests to buy
their own food at nearby facilities or
vending machines yeah they expected
guests to purchase their own food at a
wedding reception why so stingy oh just
because the happy couple had decided to
spend their entire food budget on
appearances by official mini and mickey
mouse costumed cast members as many were
quick to point out weddings at disney
come with a minimum catering budget so
it's likely the story was fabricated or
exaggerated but it nonetheless struck a
nerve with the twitterverse because if
there's one place the internet loves to
aim its collective ire it's at the
disney extended universe's enthusiastic
adult acolytes from disney bounders who
go to the park and outfits inspired by
their favorite characters two rich
tick-tockers moving into a gated
community of disney world mansions the
folks at karaoke night who bring the
mood down with a passionate rendition of
god help the outcasts from the hunchback
of notre dame
[Music]
enthusiasm for disney just seems to rub
the general public the wrong way and to
be fair and balanced um i confess to one
singing a song i'll make a man out of
you from the movie mulan at a karaoke
bar in northfield minnesota i think it
was the summer of 2009 and to all who
were in attendance i formally apologize
so the backlash over this foodless
disney wedding eventually spurred
professor of religious studies dr jody
eichler levine to bravely step into the
discourse she urged the very online
folks to have a little compassion for
disney adults
why because according to eichler levine
disney adulting is akin to practicing a
religion and we ought to be a little
more sensitive to people's sacred
experiences at the church of mickey
mouse in the name of the minnie mickey
and donald duck hey man don't put that
in the video in her sympathetic twitter
thread she writes if we measure religion
not by its truth claims but by its power
in people's lives then disney is as much
a religion as anything it is at the very
least a site of meaning and human
fellowship even if you hate it she
argues that people embrace disney for
various personal reasons maybe disney
world was the only place where your
parents ever seemed happy maybe you
watched frozen on your first date with
your spouse or maybe you found solace
dumping your favorite uncle's ashes on
splash mountain please don't try the
last one it's very much illegal but this
argument caused many to wonder was
eichler levine defending disney adults
or offering an unflattering diagnosis of
their spiritual condition and does
disney fandom really have that much in
common with religious worship let's take
a step back and start by approaching
disney adults as a fandom scholar
cornell sandvos writes that fandom is
defined by the regular emotionally
involved consumption of a given popular
narrative or text so disney lovers who
have cried over mufasa's death three
thousand times
certainly would seem to fit the bill now
the link between fandom and religion has
long been discussed in academic circles
in fact the word fan even has religious
etymology coming from the latin word
fanaticus which meant attendant of the
temple or the fanus
or fainus
fan of i'll say it fan of the anus is
what it sounds like and that's fine and
of course deeply religious people are
often called fanatics it's also the name
of the philadelphia philly's very
chaotic looking mascot as scholar vernon
chadwick argues the latin root of
religion religio is defined not in terms
of the truth of dogma but the strength
of communal bonds forms by shared belief
such a community can manifest around
shared rites of worship or sacred
objects or sites chadwick explains that
taking care of and maintaining these
elements of a religion easily becomes
ends in themselves
independent of explicitly defined and
defended articles of belief this is all
to say religion can be viewed less as
what you believe and more as what you do
and this makes sense as many organized
religions place a big emphasis on
religion being about acts of service and
lived virtues friend of the channel
soaring character guard also out those
few calling christianity a practice
rather than just being a system of like
bullet pointed beliefs and folks have
long been squeaked out by what intense
fans do in their communities
specifically because of the seeming
proximity to religious experience for
example when elvis's gyrating hips made
children fall into tearful hysterics
some parents got real nervous because
huge emotional reactions were ideally
meant for church revivals not sexual
awakenings via the ed sullivan show
christian groups even worried that
christian contemporary music would
distract its fans from worshiping god
and lead them towards secularism instead
it just made millions and millions of
dollars and produced gems like this if
you do drugs and you think you're cool
you need to come to sunday school what's
more the conventional language we use to
talk about fandom certainly invokes
religion we call niche fandoms cults and
talk about our culture of celebrity
worship so it's no wonder scholars of
religion media and fandom alike have
grappled for decades with the question
do fandoms constitute a religion as
scholar mark duffett put it because fan
phenomena can sometimes look similar to
moments of religious ecstasy the idea
that fandom is like a religion is a
ready-made metaphor i also like the
notion of religious ecstasy like going
to church on ecstasy that sounds fun
don't do it but do it duffett notes that
some academic researchers who subscribed
to this interpretation of fandom treated
fans with empathy while others use the
analogy to stereotype and land-based
fans as servile and misguided that is to
say to treat fandom as a religious
practice sometimes means to pathologize
the fan i.e to regard or treat them as
psychologically abnormal or unhealthy
it's worth noting that some forms of
fandom are basically treated as normal
by our society while others are viewed
with skepticism nobody's gonna call you
a cultist for wearing your tom brady
jersey for a week leading up to the
super bowl but if you carry around your
replica of thor's hammer for a week
leading up to the new mcu movie people
will probably have thoughts and we
certainly see plenty of pathologizing
when it comes to disney adults
especially on the internet articles with
titles like disney adults are the most
terrifying people on the planet and they
need to be stopped regularly pop up with
assertions that disney adults penchant
for getting off on nostalgia is worse
than being an actual serial killer
though come to think of it a serial
killer who is also a disney adult
would be the most nightmarish thing i
could ever imagine but snarky twitter
users didn't invent this kind of
cultural pathologizing many early
scholars of then burgeoning mass culture
approached early fans much the same way
specifically a marxist powerhouse of
german intellectuals who formed what's
called the frankfurt school sort of like
the goof troop of cranky philosophers
members included dudes like theodore
adorno walter benamin and max horkheimer
who collectively pioneered the
discipline we now know as critical
theory critical theory views philosophy
and social theory's primary purposes as
being tools to critique social and
political structures of power and when
several of these folks fled nazi germany
for america they found plenty to
critique about its culture writing for
vox sean elling explains they saw the
yoke of capitalist ideology wherever
they looked in films in radio and
popular music in literature adorno
called this the culture industry and
italy notes he cautioned that it blurred
the distinction between truth and
fiction between the commercial and the
political as journalist and author
stuart jeffries explains these scholars
wondered why a socialist revolution had
swept across russia while failing to
manifest in advanced industrialized
nations like germany and the united
states he writes they concluded that
culture and the use of the media was the
primary tool for oppressing the masses
without the masses realizing that
they're being oppressed and so the
argument went mass culture with its
flashy lights and captivating narratives
was indoctrinating people into dominant
ideologies i.e ways of thinking that
wouldn't threaten or upset those in
positions of economic and political
power the culture industry thus caused
people to unconsciously and
unquestioningly accept what the people
in power wanted them to believe in this
way these scholars thought that culture
was essentially taking the place of and
functioning like an organized religion
note that during this time religion was
undergoing a decline in power over the
national psyche as a dordo and
horkheimer wrote the sociological theory
that the loss of the support of
objectively established religion has led
to cultural chaos is disproved every day
for culture now impresses the same stamp
on everything that is to say culture was
indoctrinating people into the sorts of
dominant ideologies which were once
exclusively the terrain of religion this
development upset these guys to no end
and adorno even penned a hateful paper
about the insidious national disease of
jazz music
like who doesn't like jazz music it's
really nice
what's interesting though is who made
jazz music at that time
so god only knows what he would think of
contemporary disney culture with all its
mouse ears season passes and disney
themed funeral companies oh and we're
not making that last one up if i ever
die and you
dare to bury me in mickey mouse ears i'm
gonna come back as a hybrid zombie and
ghost and just haunt the sh out of you
anyway going forward scholars wouldn't
all share a dorno's scorn for mass
culture in the 60s england's birmingham
school of cultural studies started to
take fans especially working-class ones
more seriously and in the 80s and 90s
fandom scholarship really took a turn
away from those old unflattering
portraits that's thanks largely to the
work of academics like henry jenkins who
were also fans these aca fans were
already immersed in the fandom cultures
they were studying and were thus more
sympathetic instead of diagnosing fans
as docile and semi brainwashed from afar
these scholars asked fans how and why
they interacted with their chosen media
texts also i would like to announce that
i'm officially now an akka fan of the
television show scrubs okay sasha let's
see what your new engine can do
they asserted that fans weren't
uncritically absorbing ideologies in
mass media and blindly adhering to the
status quo
rather they saw the way fans would poach
ideas and characters and stories from
the things they liked they would then
remake and remix them to align with
their own values often to tell
subversive countercultural stories if
you lived through tumblr in the 2010s
you've seen enough destiel and kirk and
spock slash to know exactly what they
mean even if i have no idea what i just
said
i love you
this poaching can also be seen in some
activities of disney adults take garrett
smith and jason bittner who dressed as
woody and buzz for their elaborate toy
story themed wedding remaking disney
canon to fit their love story i can only
hope it was officiated by a friend in a
mr potato head outfit this wave of
scholars took a utopian view of fandom
and felt it was important not to see
fans as cultish or worshipful but as
enthusiastic thoughtful consumers of
media a lot of us appreciate the fact
that it presents a very positive view of
the future
it doesn't show the earth being
devastated by war as it shows us having
finally figured out how to solve our
worst problems that's because these
scholars and fans saw religiosity as
equivalent to irrationality and painted
religion as an unfounded belief in
something supernatural and ultimately
not real and henry jenkins phrasing
calling fans religious paints them as
prone to false beliefs orgastic excess
possession and madness and clearly he's
talking about disney character cosplay
orgies there and i would like to see it
labeling fans as religious fanatics he
said can also be inherently othering and
stigmatizing it makes them out to be
obsessive devotees who look at captain
kirk as a literal deity and pray to
obi-wan kenobi for wisdom these scholars
tried to distance fan culture from
religion and defined fans as rational
autonomous media consumers and critics
as jenkins puts it as a religion you
bring back in this notion of literal
belief and it implies that fans are
unable to separate fiction from reality
or that they supposedly act on the text
as if it were literally true however
this according to many religious
scholars is a problematic view of
religion for one it paints religious
people as childish irrational and
disconnected from the real world it
asserts that they don't question their
text and take them as absolute truth
what's more it maps western conceptions
of religion specifically christianity
onto hugely diverse cultural traditions
that may bear little to no resemblance
to it not all religious movements
require literal beliefs in the
supernatural or deities not all
religions make grand truth claims or
posit a metaphysical realm or even have
a cohesive set of traditions scholars
carol m cusack and venesha laura delano
robertson explain religion is today
studied as not exclusively a
tradition-based or faith-based practice
but a rationale an experience so when
scholars of religion compare the
experiences of disney adults to those of
religious adherents they're not
asserting that a disney file drinking
water from each of the park's fountains
believes themselves to be consuming the
literal trans-substantiated blood of his
lord and savior donald duck nor do they
mean that someone brought to tears by a
fireworks display truly believes
themselves to be witnessing fairy magic
instead they see disney lovers as
participating in a secularized version
of religious fervor in which they
encounter a deeply personal and
experiential connection to something
bigger than themselves so clearly
there's been some scholarly disagreement
some justify viewing fandom's embrace of
culture as a kind of replacement for
religion others think that fans are
doing something very different so with
scholars disagreeing on the question of
whether or not disney can properly be
considered a religion we think the best
way to get to the bottom of this
question is to step back and reconsider
the question
what makes a religion anyway and then we
can see how much overlap there is
between organized religion as it's
commonly practiced and the habits and
practices of the disney adult community
one thing that's for sure is that
there's no organized religion that says
it's cool to leave menacing comments on
the wedding photos of a gentle youtube
host but we'll get to all that in part
two
where we'll also be asking is there
anything that disney adults can tell us
about contemporary society
other than that the most important thing
you can do when planning a wedding is
keep your guests well fed and with fresh
drinks in hand so check back later this
week to watch us try and answer all
those questions once and for all
assuming of course that a gang of irate
disney adults don't kidnap me first so
if you see me blink twice in the next
video i'm in trouble call for help in
the meantime let us know your thoughts
on the church of walt in the comments a
big thanks to our patrons for all your
support and be sure to check out our
revamped patreon page show off your
fandom by giving this video the old
thumbs up hit that subscribe button like
you're pulling down the safety bar on
space mountain and don't forget to ring
that bell and as always thanks for
watching and be sure to check out part
two
[Music]
you